You have worked with a lot of extraordinary men.
I mean Moneypenny, Bond, hello.
I know.
(audience clap)
Moneypenny, how about those extraordinary men?
I've been very, very lucky actually.
I've kissed some amazing men.
I mean, it's brilliant.
Another perk of the job.
It's a real great perk, isn't it?
It really is.
I love it.
There are some men you're more excited
to kiss than others.
I will admit that.
There are lots of men I was excited to kiss,
I have to admit.
That's my point!
I love it.
I mean, Idris Elba, for instance, it was amazing.
(audience clap)
Drew, can I just say
that you're just getting everything out of me.
Yes, yes!
This topic, I'm like, we just started,
where are we gonna go?
Is it true that you actually did get
in a little bit of trouble
for rumoring Idris Elba
as the next Bond?
Oh yes, I did.
Yeah, it's a really dangerous thing
when you answer the question, who's gonna be the next Bond?
I thought I'll just offer up a name.
I was working with Idris at the time,
so I said, Idris Elba.
And then the title was,
"Naomi says Idris Elba to be next Bond."
That went everywhere.
Did the broccoli family say?
No, they knew that I'd fallen into the journalist traps.
Perfect, okay.
Yeah, that was okay.
But then Idris held it against me
'cause he was like,
"In every interview, I have to answer questions
"about being the next Bond."
Sometimes I like weird avant garde questions.
Will you play my favorite game with me?
Okay, let's do it.
Okay, in honor of your alien run-ins on your new show,
"The man who fell to Earth",
we're gonna play "The final five".
(audience clap)
Number one, what travel destination
would you bring an alien to here on Earth?
I would take them to Costa Rica
because I'm obsessed with Costa Rica
so they'd have to see it with me.
All right, number two,
have you ever witnessed anything extra terrestrial?
I have not.
I have to tell you, my mom and my stepdad,
they go out a lot of nights with their deck chairs
and they go to these secret locations where they hear
that aliens have appeared
and they wait all night for them to appear.
Were they excited for this role for you
if they kind of love the other world?
They haven't seen it yet,
but they're super excited about it.
Yeah, it's totally their kind of thing.
Okay, number three,
what human trait would you teach to an alien?
I think the most important human trait is forgiveness.
Where can we go without forgiveness?
(audience clap)
Of self as well, other people and of self.
Okay, what is the first food that you would introduce
to an alien?
A green smoothie 'cause it's very healthy
and I want them to be healthy and last a long time.
And last but not least, would you ever date an alien?
Absolutely, yes, no hesitation there!
Thank you Naomi Harris.
"The man who fell to Earth"
is available April 24th on Showtime
and I will say it is a magnificent show.
It is really extraordinary.
I think it's gonna turn heads
and you guys are incredible in it,
and it is really well done.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)